hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde ich darf euch heute mal
wieder recht herzlich willkommen heißen
zu einer neuen episode ebay fails mit
luca eurem vollidioten vom dienst hallo
suchen sie noch jemand mit freundlichen
grüßen hallo ich suche noch jemanden
okay okay
hätten wir das auch direkt zu beginn
geklärt ja hallo ist das auto noch zu
haben ja motor getriebe ist alles in
ordnung ist das auto fahrbereit ja was
kann es in paris machen
ich weiß nicht genau war auch noch nie
da da gibt es auf jeden fall den
eiffelturm und damit meine lieben
freunde würde ich sagen soll wieder
direkt in der dummheit denn als nächstes
verkauft eine person auf ebay einen
designer hund für 1700 euro und das foto
was er an gehangen hat von dem designer
und ist das hier eine art mini und 100
vegan
alles klar
alles klar wir verkauft jemand für fünf
euro insgesamt vier kisten auf ebay und
ein potenzieller käufer fragte hey was
sind die massen
liebe grüße also ich glaube an mein team
maße allerdings antwortet der verkäufer
drei ikea kissen und ein kleines kissen
ebenfalls von ikea sind sie waschbär
ja
wenn die ereignisse schönen guten tag
ich würde gerne die scheinwerfer meine
mercedes von ihnen aufbereiten lassen
muss von einem termin machen wie sind
ihre öffnungszeiten vielen dank im
voraus hallo ich mache nur außen
scheinwerfer ja ihnen hat man ja
meistens keine sie haben geschrieben von
ihnen ja von ihnen und nicht von innen
ich mache nur außen nicht ihnen manchmal
frage ich mich ob wir hier bei ebay
felsen oder uns in irgendeiner
irrenanstalt verliert haben apropos
irrenanstalt allerdings meine lieben
freundin die nächsten vier bilder sind
keine e mail fällt sondern klopapier
fails ich frage mich wirklich wer so
irre ist jetzt knop also ich mal schaut
euch das hier zum beispiel einfach an
da hängt jemand an seinen gartenzaun
wc-papier 10 cent pro blatt oder auch
hier
da seht ihr schmuck und halt eine rolle
klopapier für 200 euro daneben
und dann habe ich tatsächlich auch auf
ebay mal nach klopapier geschaut und
habe zum beispiel dieses angebot
gefunden
gestricktes klopapier waschbar für 100
euro
dann habe ich weiter gesucht sind aber
dass sie gefunden eine rolle klopapier
65 eur 800 euro für eine ganze packung
klopapier im ort eutin im ort spremberg
wird eine klopapier packung im
originalen zustand für 100 euro verkauft
und in rödelheim für 300 euro eine rolle
was trauriges
es gibt 1000 prozentig auch leute die
daran wirklich das geld investieren und
sich denken
gerade ein paar sekunden später
ich habe grade eine klopapierrolle
unterschrieben meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr 60.000 likes pakt unter diesem video
dann verlor sich die an einem von euch
kommentiert zudem gerne unten euren
instagram haben dann kann ich euch
darüber kontaktieren wenn ihr diese
klopapierrollen einem gesamtwert von 7
milliarden euro gewinnen wollt machen
allerdings weiter mit diesem befehl und
verkauft dort eine person ein apple
iphone 11 pro max 256gb der interessent
schreibt bitte macht 300 euro kaufe
sofort 1100 euro festpreis bitte ich
habe familie und kein geld habe auf
ihrem profil geschaut sie haben eine
anzeige drin in der die felgen für ihren
bmw z4 gehen 29 suchen ist jetzt nicht
das typische familienauto und zudem ist
es das aktuelle modell also haben sie
dafür wohl geld übrig bist du schnell
falls ja wer kennt die nächste reform
ist der altbekannte detektiv hier sucht
eine person auf ebay kleinanzeigen einen
kart her und eine person schreibt ihr
kann ich sie haben erst mal hallo und
der kater wird gesucht
ok melde dich wenn sie wieder da ist
was
ich checke halt viele nachrichten
einfach wirklich gar nicht wenn
nächstenliebe fällen haben wir
allerdings wieder einen reim am start
und zwar rosen sind rot ich kotze von
langeweile im strahl als zeitvertreib
setze ich mich aufs klo und denn zweimal
der war stark der war
der doc was wäre ihr endpreis hallo 250
euro kann ich machen 150 würde ich die
nehmen wieso soll ich dir 130 euro
schenken kannst du mir das erklären
wegen co
ich glaube wir können euch erklären was
da stand was mit c anfängt und so weiter
und so fort das ding ist halt leider
youtube.de monetarisiert alle videos in
denen dieses aktuelle thema drin
vorkommen von daher habe ich das jetzt
gerade aus gips aber wie dreist kann man
sein zu sagen ich gebe dir 100 euro oh
mein gott der andere typ kann er gar
nicht rechnen wert hier 250 euro
geschrieben
da fragt er auch 150 geht und er denkt
250 150 130 euro sammer bist du dumm
irgendwie sind alle parteien gerade dom
der verkäufer der käufer und ich
nächsten feld und zwar ist es wieder ein
rein meine lieben freunde und er handelt
von diesem regal und zwar lautet der
rose sind rot der rest ist egal kauft
endlich das regal ja dass watch muss ich
auch zensieren genauso wenn ich jetzt
sage du kleiner
do
allerdings nun direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten ebay fällt er wieder in die
aktuelle situation perfekt rein passt
und was ist das hier das ist
desinfektionsmittel und er schreibt in
den titel der anzeige tausche
desinfektionsmittel gegen drei zimmer
wohnung in stuttgart und in der
beschreibung steht je nach lage und
größe der wohnung ist noch eine
zuzahlung zu leisten das ist zwar alles
ganz witzig so mit diesen ganzen jobs
die dann nicht nur wie bei kleinanzeigen
rum flattern sondern auch auf ein gag
und auf irgendwelche mime seite und so
weiter und so fort allerdings ist es
halt wirklich war
ich habe gegen die letzten das gesehene
wirklich bei netto oder bei real kostete
einfach drei von diesen
desinfektionsmitteln in die 9 90 euro
oder so ich mein fach denke sagt ihr
dass jetzt das nächste angebot und zwar
ist das ein echter schnuppert für 99
euro in der beschreibung steht verkauft
wird ein echter rothbart elf monate alt
erster hand aufgewachsen in finning
hauptsächlich im freien sehr gepflegtes
echthaar keine china ware tägliche
wartung durch öl und spezial sehr gut
geeignet für fasching zum beispiel pirat
aber am liebsten wird der als schenkel
bürste eingesetzt ja so ein angebot
könnte ich mit meinem buch leider nicht
erstellen hallo hallo
hey ihre adresse schicken bitte
hallo hallo hallo
das beschreibt eigentlich diese ebay
fels folgen in einem bild machen
allerdings nun weiter mit einem ebay
fälle wo eine person einen schuh von
dior kaufen will
also jemand anderes verkauft seinen dior
schuh deswegen fragt der rechnung
fragezeichen und andere personen
antwortet am nächsten morgen war ein
geschenk von einem sehr guten freund der
einen bioladen leitet daher leider keine
rechnung bruder du glaubst du doch
selber nicht viel glück ja salami auf
arte geblieben er las weiter inschallah
verkauf sein herz richtig einfach
veräppeln wir nur so sagt nee mein
kollege hatten dior laden deswegen hab
ich leider keine rechnung du mir leid
denn ist sie befällt ist so richtig
albern ich weiß schaut euch einfach an
eine person schreibt machen sie das und
die andere person antwortet servus ich
habe ihnen versehentlich einen cent in
klammern 1 cent zu viel überwiesen
könnten sie mit diesen einen cent
möglicherweise zurück erstatten da es
mir finanziell nicht sehr gut geht und
weil sie keinen anspruch auf dieses geld
haben
entschuldigung für diese störung am
späten abend mit freundlichen grüßen
mach ich
da finde ich eigentlich gar nicht
aufhören zu klatschen ehrlich gesagt
dass er jetzt ein beitrag der in eine
ebay kleinanzeigen facebook-gruppe
gepostet wurde und zwar schreibt dort
jemand suche billiges doppelbett mit
matratze gerne auch ein bett wo schon
jemand drin gst
dann aber geschenkt was ist mit einigen
menschen los allerdings nun auch schon
zum vorletzten email fällt für die
heutige episode und zwar ist es gar kein
richtiger ebay fail sondern das
komplette gegenteil eigentlich und zwar
schreibt eine person erledigt und vielen
dank nochmal also sie hat ein produkt
gekauft von einer anderen person die
daraufhin geantwortet hat vielen dank
bringe es nachher zur post habe alles
möglichst vorsichtig eingepackt damit es
nicht zu sehr zerknittert und dann
einige tage später als das produkt
angekommen ist antwortet die person
heimat leben ich bin so glücklich mit
den gardinen und sie passen perfekt ich
habe dir gerade noch mal zehn euro
zusätzlich überwiesen da ich irgendwie
fand dass sie das wert waren also danke
nochmal liebe grüsse emma
das ist so eine richtige ehrenmann
aktion war allerdings sind auch schon
zum letzten für die heutige episode
allerdings spielt sich das ganze nicht
auf ebay ab sondern auf amazon und zwar
ist es dass hier ein herren
business-anzug home office sechserpack
und es sind einfach es sind halt einfach
boxershorts
es ist die wahrheit ich habe mich
gestern mit einem kumpel unterhalten der
selber auch gerade die ganze zeit hoffe
das macht dann sitzt die ganze zeit in
boxershorts aber dann oben rum mit hemd
und sakko vor seinem computer wieder mit
seinen chefs und soll er redet und
stelle mich dass heute wieder nicht
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat die heutige wieso die
ebay ventil denke ich will unbedingt
diese unterschriebene klopapierrolle von
luca gewinnen dann lasst ein like und am
video da und denkt nicht 1000 like
schaue ich in die kommentare und
derjenige der da irgendwer da seinen
instagram namen ehre kommentiert und und
liegt an der stelle auch noch mal kurz
sagen dass ich wegen dieser ganzen zu
hause bleiben zeigt jetzt hat extrem
viel zeit einfach habe von daher hab ich
heute auch noch acht monaten mal wieder
ein video auf dem youtube kanal
hochgeladen in dem ich auf leute
reagiere die weil ja gerade alle
friseure geschlossen haben sich selber
die haare geschnitten haben und das halt
nicht so gut hingekriegt haben hier oben
findet ihr ein smiley angewendet wenn
ihr darauf könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren das kostenlos und verpasst
keine videos mehr und soeben ist
selbstverständlich auch eine neue folge
des podcast von sandra und mehr online
gegangen die kontrollen link dazu unten
in der video beschreibung